I signed up to fight in the war been in
full Boston accent plays Joe Coughlin
son of a cop gone to the dark side I
went away a soldier I came home an
outlaw there's the money my father says
there once was a good man in you I want
to be a gangsta stop kissing rings a
long time ago he becomes a bootlegger
and rum runner in 1920s Florida you
don't think I'm strong enough I don't
know if you're cruel enough powerful men
don't have to be cruel making life more
complicated and dangerous are the two
femme fatales bins involved with zoe
saldana and Sienna Miller we do what we
want to do go where we want to go Xion
also happens to be the mistress of
another gangster you spend your life
hoping someone will punish you for your
sins Here I am in this fourth drama
directed by Affleck his character seems
caught up in a world he can't control I
realized to be free in this life
breaking the rules meant nothing
you had to be strong enough to make your
own that looks wow it looks like my kind
of movie then also wrote the screenplay
for live by night and if you remember he
won his first Oscar for co-writing good
will hunting with Matt Damon yes he did
ok listen up lady